hey YouTube averse coming up next star
talk cosmic queries the deep edition
this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and I got with
me Chuck nice hey Chuck today it's
cosmic queries that's one of our
favorite forms I love it I love it I
love it I love it and we aren't in fact
educated people
my mom is spinning a grave right now so
but this is a cosmic queries of a topic
we've never solicited no we have not
yeah what and what a topic is the deep
deep space deep thoughts deep questions
questions what would Chuck you got it
give it in your deepest voice okay here
we go
and by the way we did this one yes we
did and I think I I think I beat you by
a half a tone or yeah just barely I'm
here no here we go all right deep
thoughts yeah you got me already see I
got a drink scotch smoker cigar I got a
smoke a cigar smoke see and I'll just
fix that right then it becomes like a
deep voice and like somewhat Harvey
Fierstein raspy yes deep so I'd sorts
scotch doesn't give you their hearty
fired by acid someone call me a noob
I've had too much drink all right all
right let's get deep deep thoughts cuz
usually there isn't a right answer so
you just get to sort of play with it and
see where it takes you yeah all right so
this is deep questions only all right
let's do it
so solicited from our fan base it's from
our fan base and as usual we start with
a patreon patron because they're fans
that pay us and nothing says fandom like
that
alright by the way are different levels
you can be a bit on the way page what's
the lowest level it's five bucks a maxi
you can go down the two two dollars a
month but we really want you to come in
at five so that you can get the perks of
getting our videos alright being able to
get extra content and we revamped that
we read your name I don't remember
what's in the list one of them I think
do you you come on the show yes that
that's the best put you on start off yes
you come on the show and you are a guest
on the show right and you get to ask all
the questions you want that's cool man
you know what I would do we didn't say
whether we'd actually hear it that's so
wrong no no by the way wouldn't that be
the ultimate like rip open it's like
when can I expect to see this oh you can
unfortunately all right so let's go with
our patreon patron and here's the
question from Jonathan wax and Jonathan
says or ask what boggles your mind more
than the thought of endless time or the
thought of endless space so it's
impossible to truly contemplate endless
time because you would spend the rest of
your existence doing so
well here's two things bother me okay
there's a beautiful frontier of research
going on in the field of neuroscience
cool interesting so I have two questions
related to that that boggle my mind okay
well write these down
can the human brain
figure out the human mind
so great fit is the human brain that
actually creates it creates the human
mind mmm that's so good I'm saying yes
or do you need something outside of that
right that is greater smarter different
so that it can come in and then
understand that as its own test Test
Kitchen Wow
no so Sagan is famously said go ahead
that humans are the universe's way to
understand itself the universe is
understanding itself through humans
through humans correct without humans
there be no thoughts right to do that
but however that elevates us higher than
I'm prepared to do so you think so yeah
because who says we are the measure of
what is intelligent in this universe is
what we do so so that statement that
Carl Sagan statement it's kind of like a
cosmological Descartes that's like the
universe the Descartes you I think
before I am kind of thing okay but it's
like we think therefore you are oh yeah
Oh Chuck every once in a while after
some we think therefore you all right
rather than I think therefore I am
yeah Oh Chuck that was beautiful oh
thanks which is in the show right now
thank you it's downhill from here but so
I wonder whether there is a level of
intelligence out there where we are
today
what chimpanzees are to us as it
interesting so for example oh that's
terrible
oh I hope not well you can go to
chimpanzee and say yeah and say tomorrow
morning at 8:30 let's go to Starbucks
and have a cup of coffee nothing in that
sentence makes any sense to a chimpanzee
right or ever will I'm pretty sure
there's a Jim Jim star but I'm just
pretty sure there is a Jim I'm just
saying you think Starbucks figured out I
guess
to be selling chimps coffee somehow some
ways that why there's a hyper at the zoo
exactly you know what I mean you go to
get your coffee it's just like Curious
George
Curious George ok so wait so so so
here's why I say that there's many times
I've written it my will tell you to your
face now alright good so there's about
1% difference in DNA between humans and
chimps yet we'd like to think of
ourselves as highly superior highly
superior intellectually to the chimp
right maybe the difference in our brain
power is as small as that 1% indicates
uh-huh so that pulling termites out of a
mound with a stick that was carefully
chosen from a branch right its rep from
from a bush maybe that is not very far
from space travel the Hubble telescope I
know this sounds crazy
maybe maybe look at those cute little
humans in there ok so now watch the
smartest chimp yeah that are studied in
labs right that are brought in Florida
thin to chip society's right you bring
them forward and what do they do though
stack boxes to reach a banana mm-hmm
they might put up an umbrella they'll do
some things
ok have rudimentary sign light our
toddlers can do right but those are the
smartest chimps right but our toddlers
do that same thing with dogs dogs have a
belt I know I can I could do this
example for dogs as well but is that
simpler because they're closer to even
closer dad's here dad to see what you're
doing do you see where I'm going so I if
the smartest chimp equals our toddler
and there's only 1% difference in DNA
between us right
let's go 1% beyond us ooh that's scary
that's I'm saying if we go 1% beyond us
in that same vector of intelligence yeah
they're traveling at the speed of light
then they say that light travels then
the smartest human they'll roll forward
they'll take they'll take Stephen
Hawking and they'll say this human is
slightly smarter than the rest
because he can do astrophysics
calculations in his head right like
little Timmy over here who just came
home from alien preschool right
the toddler the toddler right and say oh
you just compose a sonnet isn't it cute
let's put it up on the refrigerator oh
you just derived the principles of
calculus oh isn't that cute funny so if
so if the smartest human does what their
toddlers can do right their average
people will have thoughts they will have
sentences that will rise above and
beyond our most brilliant capacity to
understand and I stay awake at night
wondering whether the universe has
complexities in it that are out of reach
of the neuro synapses of the human brain
Wow that's my answer
so there's information out there that we
just cannot conceive more perky don't
even know how to how to access that
write about it to get an answer correct
we don't know the answer we don't know
the question to get an answer to get an
answer right not that we don't know it
because we haven't been told it yeah no
we just can't concede can't conceive it
so you go to a chimp and say go to a
chimp and say uh what would it be Oh
something as simple as navigating the
Stars to get someplace right can't do
that stars what right navigate right
what spaceship what rocket fuel what
none of that none of it you can't even
have that conversation right so that's
my point
yeah now I'm thinking that the whole
thing might be some type of like science
experiment by some alien kid now this
that does not wanna we are all a
simulation in an alien kids basement who
has a mu data out of the house she had
that's so funny we're the minecraft of
some other minecraft yes
wow wow that yeah yeah then when things
get too peaceful and stable they stir
the pot stir the pot it's throwing a
politician a war a crazy person throwing
thing and then oh now is entertaining so
we just entertainment for this is the
best video game
okay wow man that's a listen that's a
great answer to what boggles your mind
that's a really yeah it doesn't much
boggle my mind it upsets my mind yeah I
was about to say it's very upsetting or
we're not I'm mad I'm leaving a wide
like here's my one out place you like go
ahead because
for humans our knowledge is cumulative
so true you don't have to invent
calculus somebody else did that right
you just have to use it right learn it
and use it right so I have the feeling
that we are every next generation that
has sort of brilliant people
contributing to our understanding of the
universe they're adding our rung to a
ladder right then we all sort of climb
cook up better and then just get that
next wrong what's wrong well with that
in mind I think that the next
evolutionary step for human beings is
that we will create an intelligence
greater than our own that's really the
deal this scares the hell out of
everyone yeah because that intelligence
will say we don't need you and you know
what and we'd have to say you're right
that's what happened in the matrix yeah
you are virus on this earth mr. Anderson
I smell you mr. Anderson no he was
smelling that's right get your matrix if
you get if you go there in front of me
I'm in front of the Roswell favorite
movie that's true don't even yes he was
talking about Morpheus or hide up in the
chair
yes it's the smell really serious Bo for
a computer to tell you stake through the
electronics so this is Alex Greg 56 from
Instagram and Alex Greg says this if the
universe needs not make any sense to us
then what is the point of doing science
is science not in fact the discipline of
trying to grasp what's around us by the
way is this statement not equal to the
old one which is God has his reason to
make it that way so just don't ask
course I never heard that expression but
that the shorter version of that is God
works in mysterious ways that is so true
when you can't explain any can as well
God the Lord Merton's
right and if you can't explain it using
God than you do right O God is blessed
you you bless got something you know
then there's a tsunami takes out a
quarter million people God hates you but
no one says that no one says that why
don't we say that we should say that you
know I want to start saying you know
what I think God hates you
well the most hateful God in our culture
is the one represented on insurance
forms oh that's so true
acts of God acts of God right it's only
Eve very bad things
oh no one says flowers bloomed in your
garden an act of God no it's tsunami
took out your house that's you know
you're homeless on the street act of God
Wow look at that this moment of God
hates you bought to you by farmers in
what's that one nationwide is not on
your side nationwide is on your side
God is not okay that's enough so maybe
some hate mail now so the so is science
in fact the discipline of trying to
graphs what is around okay so what he
started what started quoting me where I
said I opened my book the astrophysics
with people in a hurry right with the
quote
the universe is under no obligation to
make sense to you right okay what that
means is mmm-hmm
your five traditional senses which rose
up out of the Serengeti okay
which help us not get eaten by lions
right right
they're very good at that they're not as
good at contemplating infinity they're
not good contemplating timescales much
longer than your life expectance so true
you don't you can't Intuit billions of
years you can't Intuit infinitesimal
there are things that are hard for us
right there are things that may even be
impossible for us can you picture a five
dimensional cube no I cannot no you
cannot keep put your 4 dimensional cube
probably not no actually the tesseract
is closed yeah that's a like a I can I
can actually picture that because I've
seen a drawing I I have a tesseract do
you relate it oh all right well I'm not
bringing in wait another episode another
episode will be the episode of higher
dimensions sweet to a whole thing I'm
just hired yeah I like that we did we do
that already
how come I don't remember man I'm
getting old
did I have my tesseract in my hand well
now we got do it again which I took this
from Thanos
what it means is if you are going to
deduce what is or is not true in the
universe right your senses are not the
most reliable measure of whether it's
true so true
I guess the senses give you a restricted
understanding of what's actually going
on in the universe your eyes you would
never trade them for anything yet they
only expose your your mind to a very
tiny narrow strip of all the
electromagnetic energy that's out there
well you can't see infrared you can feel
it as heat you can't see it right
ultraviolet you can't see that either
you can feel that in a delayed sense by
getting sunburned or skin cancer
it's not telling you in that instant
it's a time delay but keep going out
there's Bob infrared ultraviolet x-ray
gamma rays can't see any of that but the
universe is talking to you in that so
you gonna say my senses give me
everything that there is in the universe
and therefore it makes sense no as long
as we detect things that fall outside of
our senses it's a challenge for you to
declare that what we say do and discover
makes sense the very statement makes
sense means your senses can contemplate
it that your senses have experience if I
let go of a ball and it floats up you'll
say that doesn't make sense because your
senses always told you if you look over
ball it drops right and in fact the very
statement let it go not the present not
the frozen version but just let it go
means drop it they mean the same thing
mm-hmm
but that can only be true on earth with
a force of gravity pointing down in
space we're in free orbit you let go it
just floats this stays right there stays
right there so like my problems stay
right yeah I must be in space cuz all my
problems somebody says drop it and I say
I did that they're right still here and
you better go and tell it exactly so my
point is the methods tools are just
science give you a way to understand
what is true
without it being hinged on whether your
senses think it's true
nice so the Mets until the signs are
accessed to truth where you can still
probe the universe whereas God works in
mysterious ways kind of ends that
conversation where as I say I developed
a new instrument that can see in ways
humans cannot oh my god said opens
entire world of investigation entire
branches of suns hmm all right so it's
cosmic queries yes it is the deep with
addition deep the yes deep I think I
know the difference what I think
I think we're hitting the same note but
I have more sort of cavity resonance
this is chest cavity well you're a
bigger guy than Chuck here we go so this
is from probably asleep that's the name
of the person the name of the person
okay I like your mama didn't like you
how long do you think the human race
will actually survive Wow
I mean there's precedent for that right
well so that you can look at what is the
average life expectancy of mammals
mammal species act like and last I
checked it was around 2 million years
something like that and so we've been
around a long way to tell you have a
long way to go we've been around you
know a couple hundred thousand years in
our current anatomical form cro-magnon
form right and so that means we have a
long way to go but this presumes that
the species is not smart enough to kill
itself well then it's over oh you guys
yeah we have invented multiple ways to
kill ourselves yeah and I don't think
the elephants did or you know nobody
else did this right the mice no they're
not killing themselves all right humans
yes yeah maybe maybe cockroaches
invented human beings boy cuz when
everything's gone they're gonna be the
only ones left and it's no no then they
don't have to invent us in the first
place what kind of reasoning are you
using here they want everything else
gone no they need us to build the
structure that they then right into they
move there yeah and
I don't mind it yeah that makes that
makes perfect sense here we are yeah uh
but so I think what he's really asking
is in your estimation from your sage
opinion I give up how long do you think
we will last
I give us 20 years that's funny
no I I think we're good this is why many
people want to become a two-planet
species terraform Mars send some humans
there so if something bad happens on
earth you still have humans somewhere
else wow that is not encouraging it off
not for half the people who aren't so
and if an asteroid comes if a killer
virus if AI goes that gets out of hand
I understand seeding something with a
remnant for survival of the species
that's extraneous I mean that's that's
something that's outside of our own
destruction you know even though we
could stop an asteroid from hitting us
if we know how we did no way nobody
doing it no and if we put the resources
into it we could stop even that from so
what's the example you give so what do
you mean to stop the astral you know
what so so what I'm saying is you know
will we ever get to a place where the as
the Buddhist monks call it the so-called
monkey brain that causes us to do so
much destructive work to each other and
to the planet will we ever get to a
place where we overcome that or were
able to train those who come behind us
to overcome that okay now it does happen
in some people I get it I first I've
never heard a Buddhist monk say the
phrase monkey brains you feel a monkey
brain today all right this is oh I've
heard of reptilian brain but not monkey
brain yes okay so the reptilian brain is
referenced something primal right that
goes on within you so if we follow the
reasoning by Steven Pinker
in his book the better angels of our
nature he studied did likelihood of you
dying before maturity or dying before
adulthood we're just dying from at the
hands of another human from early days
of tribal warfare to modern days of
state sanctioned global warfare and what
he found is that the likelihood of you
dying in that way has been dropping ever
since
okay so tribal warfare you could you
would kill maybe a third or half of the
other tribe and/or the entire tribe and
then you win and you get their land that
doesn't happen today true the state
surrenders before that happened true
saving the lives of the rest of the
population if you look at I did this
just recently if you look at what
countries had the greatest percent of
their population died in the Second
World War I thought was it Belarus one
of them is very HEIs like a third
alright I forgot the exact numbers but
they're high but they're not a half and
you keep going down and you get to to
even combat Germany even ones that were
heavily bombed Germany Japan a fraction
of the total population that is not how
it used to end in tribal warfare so
now consider that even so during the
Second World War between 1939 and 1945
1000 you maneuver for every hour from
1939 to 1945 is that going on today no
no no although real we're really
slipping just so we can bet yeah so the
point is often that error is called the
greatest generation right because they
fought you know evil forces and you know
this sort of thing although my father
fought in a segregated army so he's not
thinking that was the greatest
generation he has other out perspectives
on that period the second greatest
generation my point is is the greatest
generation the one where the fewest
fraction of everyone dies
out of hate we might have a lot of hate
but if the number of people who die from
it is lower than ever before right then
this arc that you were hinting at that
maybe a next generation learns from the
previous one maybe that's gonna work
Europe with all of their turbulence in
turmoil they actually haven't been at
war with each other for 70 years right
is there another 70 year period in the
history of Europe where nobody was
fighting anybody
nah I don't think so not if Twitter has
anything what you saying is imagine if
Twitter existed back then back then oh
but I would say some would we the war
wouldn't have stopped until everybody
was dead people would have said I'd I
surrender the tweet would have gone out
every life I take it back let's keep
fighting I don't care I hate you more
so maybe we are getting kinder kinder
and gentler mm-hmm
time still needs to bear that out on a
level that would please everyone but I
still worry that this primal brain will
always segregate us all by some
arbitrary factor and thereby justified
doing harm to other groups hmm
interesting that's I think who's the
comedian was it Franklin a jive one of
these guys from the salve attack in a
day
yeah in the day he was talking about who
hates who in the world right and he and
he says read the papers and what in
Northern Ireland the Protestants and the
Catholics are fighting each other right
and they're both white yeah you know I
don't have a chance
that's true Yeah right if white people
divide themselves up in that way right
to Christian communities killing each
other right yeah they're both white and
the both Christian and the bullet it's
over for you brothers oh it's over for
every people can't kill each other for
those reasons it's almost no hope in
this world so yeah I don't know okay
yeah so I'm sorry I'll have a good
answer no that was a pretty good answer
the answer is we're not gonna make it
I'd like to think we go thousands of
years into the future and possibly
outlive the son all right that'd be
great
like star hopping to other planetary
systems that's uh you know I'm just
gonna say that's the way it's gonna end
cuz I won't be here so that's great
maybe it has been said that the first
person who will never die is now alive
what that's it well no this how you
doing I know what you saying so they get
they get some new thing that makes you
live in extra 50 years so now you live
250 instead of a hundred and then
somewhere in there it's another thing we
get now you can live another 200 years
so no the 150 goes to 350 now you can
live 500 years now you go to a thousand
you can live 5000 years now so as we
progress in our understanding of what
ages you if we can reverse that or
prevent it from ever advancing the
person there's someone alive today who
will benefit from it that that's already
cool I like it so if that happens you
better find another planet this is true
yeah that's the premise of a show called
altered carbon where people actually
take their consciousness and put it into
what they call a sleeve which is the
body so that's I think I voiceover the
opening sequence today oh my god I think
we had that car yes what you told me
that yeah cuz I told you I don't
remember with the pilot or the other
shows but I did I lent my voice to the
cause nice Wow
all right well let's go to Joey 24 Joey
jr. 24 he says this
some question based on all your
experiences and knowledge thus far but
for me are pretty personal for you okay
yeah nobody asked me anything he says
based on all of your experiences and
knowledge thus far what do you think the
meaning of our human existence is he
just asked you what is the meaning of
life according to Neil deGrasse Tyson
okay so I are in my next book oh yeah I
don't know you never hear me plug my
stuff I was gonna say here's the meaning
of life right now the next we called
letters from an astrophysicist all right
you know what yeah correspondents I've
had with people who've had similar eggs
yes about their existence well that's
not just the book is not about that no
it's now all different consult letters
see all kinds of letters yes but a very
recurring theme is that people want to
know the meaning of life and their
significance of their life in this world
yeah and some of them come from
religious angles some are secular but
everybody's got this burning issue yes
so here's how I have dealt with it
others will do in other ways okay but
here's our ideal I'm interested now many
people are in search of the meaning of
life as though it's behind a tree right
or wrong right everybody knows it's in a
drawer in the back exactly the paperclip
that's in that drunk drawer - not like
our underwear drawer it's you know that
drawer where you go to look for stamps
and stuff oh yeah that drawer that's
right
near the kitchen somewhere right so if
you are looking for meaning
you may never find it whoo so instead
recognize that you have the power to
manufacture meeting
create it within yourself that's what I
do my meaning for life is derived by
several simple principles have I
lessened the sufferings of others today
mm-hmm that brings meaning to me because
that means the world is a little better
off because I was in it today okay if
after your day is over the world is
worse off you have subtracted meaning
hmm I should kill myself at the end
every day somebody is like that mother
so so lessen the suffering of others in
some way right doesn't mean redirect
your whole life mind body and soul but
if you can't help someone across the
street help an ageing person do you know
make it a little bit child laughs just
put a little bit of joy in the world
mm-hmm so lessen the suffering I also
try to learn something every day
all right now I'm a I'd like being a
perpetual student right most people hate
it being students this saddens me
schools finished and what he do you run
down the steps school is out forever
right who out for the summer that
attitude captured in that song mm-hmm is
as though you don't want to be in school
and what's your only job in school it's
to learn to learn and somehow that's a
chore yeah I don't blame you for feeling
that way
I believe you're this little system yeah
for not instilling within us eternal
curiosity knowing that you'll spend more
years of your life not in school than in
school and so if you have curiosity you
can be a lifelong learner that's right
and so I want to lessen the sufferings
of others and make sure iDEN to learn
something more about the world today
than I did yesterday nice and who's to
say whether that extra increment of
learning can help me be better at
blessing of lessening the sufferings of
others Oh
so that is how I make meaning in life
and as a result I own thousands of books
thousands and I read a little bit you
know I have a little stash near my bed
and I cycle them out um
and every day I try to have it's harder
now because I get recognized um but I
try to help people every day total
stranger that's nice yeah so you can
make meaning for yourself yeah look for
it because you may never find it uh you
know I'm gonna say as a philosophy that
is a that's a that's that's that's
admirable that you own the book I wrote
that in the book nice excellent thank
you give me one got one more question we
have fitted in the segment go alright
here we go
what ninja may ninja may okay there you
go I think that's your name on Instagram
says or I keep hearing the phrase the
vacuum of space
yes how exactly is it a vacuum very nice
that's a really good question right okay
so question when I was a kid a vacuum
was a physical object yes of when I
heard physicists speak of the vacuum of
space I just imagined all these Hoover's
right in the sky right I didn't know
that a vacuum was a thing was it was an
int it was a concept and then you make a
machine that duplicates that thing I
just didn't know that so I learned okay
so a vacuum is where there's basically
no air okay you can have objects there
but when we think of a vacuum it's not a
place where there isn't anything is a
place where there's no air molecules
moving typically mm-hmm all right
generally you can have some and we would
still classify it as a vacuum does you
have to distinguish like a regular old
vacuum or a perfect vacuum right now you
know what happens if there's an object
and you take away all the air molecules
the object out gasses there if there are
molecules embedded in the surface of
that object and they start coming out as
fastened
then he heat it it sends out more just
very hard to make a perfect vacuum very
hard so here's an old saying nay
sure abhorred hab horrors of a flat
these are people have never been into
space most of the universe is a vacuum
natured nerves vacuum nice the wreck was
I Trumpy in there no nerve nature lies
vacuum so perfect preferably Trumper
vacuum Trump Trump and Trump Ram vacuums
we suck the best there's another saying
there's no such thing as gravity earth
sucks ok so the point is when there's a
source of gravity all the air wants to
go to that source of gravity and it
leaves a vacuum everywhere else so a
vacuum is simply where there's no air
and it's not anything deep the odd thing
in the universe is that you have places
where air where gas molecules collect ok
those are the unusual places in the
universe and they're called stars and
gaseous planets and the atmospheres of
rocky planets nice yeah so there you
have a vacuum so Chuck I want to put put
some closure on this vacuum question ETA
ok this is the second I'm a third book I
ever published
oh ok oh just visiting this planet all
right and it's a collection of qat I had
a column a pet with a pen named Merlin
people ask fun really playful questions
that's cool they collected this is like
decades old but there's some timeless
content in here somebody asked about the
vacuum mm-hmm go ahead please Milo
well you can't read otherwise ok area
the best vacuum you will find anywhere
Brutus about this 30 years ago that's
cool the best vacuum you will find
anywhere according to four out of five
vacuum retailers and five out of five
astronomers is the void of intergalactic
space but we can then ask this
intergalactic space nothing
no it still contains space
if you feel obliged to call
intergalactic space nothing then you
must invent a word to refer to the
region outside of the universe in this
location where we presume there to be no
space there can be no nothing Wow let's
call it we're left with no choice
nothing nothing that place where there's
not even nothing
it's the nothing nothing - Wow okay I
like that and the same the truck you
want some more vacuum talk of course
I've got if I feel like you just showed
up at my door and dumped some dirt on my
carpet more vacuum talk okay bassant Oh
in death my black hole right okay this
is so in the chapter on being dense okay
I know a great deal about the range of
measured densities within our universe
is staggeringly large we find the
highest densities within pulsars where
neutrons are so tightly packed that one
thimbleful would weigh about as much as
a herd of 50 million elephants 50
million and then a rabbit disappears
into thin air and a magic show nobody
tells you that thin air already contains
over ten septal atoms per cubic meter
well sin air than air okay the best
laboratory vacuum changers can pump down
to as few as 10 billion atoms per cubic
meter Oh best vacuums that's the best
vacuum you know cubic meter 10 billion
air molecules are still walking around
okay interplanetary space gets down to
about 10 million atoms per cubic meter
hmm but while interstellar space is as
low as a half a million atoms per cubic
wow that is nothing that is well that
ain't nothing 500,000 atoms the ward the
O'War
for nothing this however must be given
to the space between the galaxies
intergalactic space where it is
difficult to find more than a few atoms
for every 10 cubic meters Wow that wins
that's that's almost that's almost
nothing nothing nothing nothing all
right we're gonna go into a deep
lightning round really we only have five
minutes left okay let's go okay here we
go
this is JA Saldana says right now what
should be the priority in the field of
space exploration searching for life
searching for potential threats of
another kind of search or is there just
no hurry at this matter at all greetings
from Mexico Mexico so what is it is it
is it in or are we looking for like he
wants my opinion I got an app
inspiration life go ahead
I got an opinion all right go ahead I
want to do it all why not do it all what
and all of the above all of the above II
because the moment you do this and not
that right they said why are you doing
that not that well because we voted that
way but maybe you don't know why you
should do that well you want to do that
some people want to do that here's what
you do
mmm-hmm you don't build a road just from
New York to LA you build roads
everywhere so that yeah I want to visit
that forest I want to visit this this
this this Rocky Monument I want to do
things that are not prescribed by you
I'm going to see the biggest ball of
yarn ever exactly right right so what
you do is you make a spaceship that is
modular strapped on different
combinations of rockets right I this
rock this combination get you to an
asteroid to mine it this gets you to the
backside of the moon this gets you to
Mars so you don't prescribe what it is
you're gonna do next in space you let
the creativity and imagination of all
those who've ever looked up say this is
what I want to do and you say here you
go two rockets from I'll be a booster
from I'll see you're on your way can I
put that on a credit card yeah that's
right yeah all right Adam in the
airwaves wants to know this from the
Instagram how far behind do you think
astronomy would be if the earth didn't
have
a moon Wow
okay so it's not how far behind we'd be
right it's how far advanced we'd be okay
so let me split this out yeah I tweeted
during space week the 50th anniversary
of the Apollo landing there's a saying
that's common in the space circles it's
if God wanted us to explore space you
would have given us a moon right okay so
good saying that's a good saying yeah
but that exploration is not
astrophysicists exploration that one is
people going into space right
we will you build a rocket to go where
you don't have a moon to visit all right
if you talk about astrophysics do you
know how many stars the naked eye can
see at night I'm more than I can Cal no
it's not it's about three to four
thousand oh really well unaided yeah
binoculars it's 100 times that yeah
telescopes it's a billion times that but
all right three or four thousand star
okay when it's a full moon out three
hundred stars
yeah right the moon weeks havoc on our
ability yeah to see the rest of the
universe so our observing schedules with
huge telescopes are split according to
dark time or bright time if you look at
if you get bright time observations it
the moon is up and you can only look at
bright objects in the night sky Wow the
deep universe only comes to us when the
moon is not up so the moon is basically
a pain in the ass it's a star blocker
Wow yes Star Barker look at that that's
what it is so strana me would be
probably half again more advanced
because we would have had these greatest
telescopes in the world looking at the
night sky twice as often right in the
darkest parts of the night sky there you
go Wow next that's a damn good answer
okay this is
uh ever sit up or I don't know what his
who cares I'm sorry
whoever that is cares let me tell you
something last time he's gonna be asking
you a question all right well you know
what your name is I'm gonna call you
George
all right so George wants to know this
what is the shape of space itself that's
a good question well space can be curved
in the presence of matter or energy as
prescribed by Einstein's general
relativity and there's the oft-repeated
saying mm-hmm
matter tells space how to curve space
tells matter how to move oh oh so space
has curvature in the presence of matter
and energy it curves in towards it with
the ultimate expression of that a black
hole where it curves in and it never
curves back out Wow all right if you
want to ask what is the shape of all of
space that's like saying what's the
shape of the universe the observable
universe it's basically a perfect sphere
Wow all right because it's your horizon
right okay it's a perfect sphere the way
when you're at sea your horizon is a
perfect circle oh that's right the same
distance in every directions right if
you're if you're just out and there's
nothing but water and so what is the
three dimensional version of a circle a
sphere a sphere so in space you can see
your horizon in every direction solid
line switches at this we it makes us
think we're at the center of a sphere
but that's no different from you
thinking you're in the center of an
ocean right
just cuz you're in the center of your
horizon that's next that's great that's
good enough right there we go for this
is a genuine who says if we look if we
were to look in all directions billions
of light years away will we see younger
universe in all directions enveloping
our bigger one now
I have to rephrase that because if as
you look out you see things not as they
are right as it were were right so you
are looking at a younger and younger and
younger universe that's the whole point
of cosmology it allows the fact that it
takes light time to reach us allows us
to see what the universe was doing in
the past right if light travelled at
infinite speeds you see the whole
universe as it is now with no evidence
of what it was once doing but because it
takes like time to move you look out you
see a younger and younger and younger
younger universe until you see the Big
Bang itself mm-hmm and that is 14
billion light years time away from us in
every direction
okay well 20 billion years ago right
okay and if you calculate that distance
through that changing time it's 14
billion light years to that horizon okay
so whether that horizon is much farther
away today right because the universe
has been expanding ever since but you'll
see it as it is today you see it as it
was right all right so um I don't to say
after that I say um yeah one last
question do a quickie car alright I
gotta fire one this you could do really
you don't know how quick I can answer
question okay I'm gonna give you one
here we go
this is this is my son did okay I don't
care what this is I'm sorry
try Chuck okay bye son buy some tickets
unting okay forget it read the name here
here's the name right there what's that
say who said
but something you're right that's what
it is but something like this
yeah okay yeah all right Wow give it to
me I should have known that that's
Indian yeah okay here we go
what if all the matter that we see in
the universe is just three dimensional
part of some four dimensional matter and
the dark gravity is just the gravity
from the 4d part that we cannot see I
love it we are so blind to a higher
dimension right it could be that all the
mysteries in our three dimensions plus
time are completely solved by looking at
this stuff from a higher higher
dimension right right right just if
you'd lived in just a flat surface it'd
be stuff going on you have no idea right
and we say look can't you just see ya
just woke up what does that giant
graphite thing making making creating
stuff right on that flat surface to just
shows up right right right so I love it
I that's the kind of universe I want it
to be cuz then when we figure out how to
see higher dimensions boom we figured
everything got a bang all that truck we
got to run all right that I enjoyed that
we show our cosmic queries the deep
addition Chuck nice tweeting a chuck
nice comic thank you sir very good I've
been your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and as always I
do you alight what am I saying
[Laughter]
[Music]